et on n'est pas donc autour d'eux nos
institutions la vème république stop ou
encore yael brunch iv bonsoir bienvenue
à sa députée leweb des yvelines
présidente de la commission des lois à
l'assemblée nationale bastien la
chaux-de-fonds soir mais à mieux vaut
aussi député les filles de
seine-saint-denis hervé marseille
bonsoir bienvenue sénateur des
hauts-de-seine président du groupe union
centriste au sénat vous soutenez valérie
pécresse j'accueille également en duplex
jean philippe derosier
constitutionnaliste bon soit il est
professeur de droit public à
l'université de lille c'est évidemment
un enjeu majeur de cette présidentielle
réconcilier les français avec leur
démocratie pourquoi on dit ça parce que
les précédents scrutins avec les records
d'abstention est elle bonne pile elles
nous ont envoyé de mauvais signaux on
craint qu'ils aient de nouveau une forte
abstention lors de cette présidentielle
est ce que ce désintérêt des français
c'est pas quand même l'un des échecs du
quinquennat du président de la
république mme asselain des échecs de
ces vingt dernières années je l ai dit
quand on regarde les courbes de
l'abstention elle ne font
malheureusement que augmenter le
désintérêt de nos compatriotes augmente
il y à une défiance donc la diffuse à
la prod la problématique démocratique
dans notre pays n'est pas nouvelle et il
est vrai que lors de ce quinquennat nous
n'avons pas réussi à résoudre la
fracture démocratique qui existe dans
notre pays malgré des grands moments
démocratiques on voit par exemple
lorsque l'on a organisé le grand débat
nos compatriotes se sont vraiment prêter
au jeu et se sont rendus par centaines
de milliers à ces réunions publiques ont
écrit des cahiers de doléances et c'est
donc on choisit l'un qu'il y a une
grande envie de débats il y a une grande
envie de démocratie il ya une grande
envie de parlements moi j'y crois
beaucoup il y a envie d'avoir des élus
qui exercent pleinement leur mission
mais on voit que la fracture existe
toujours et kung fu l'a comblé on a
compris vous réagissiez pendant les
propos de yale brune qui fait vaciller
la chaussée quoi c'était de la fausse
participation fini citoyenne ce grand
débat écouter à m'avez vous vu les
résultats qui a lu ses cahiers de
doléances que quand est il advenu
personne de lino à vous
vous avez lu et vous
qu'en avez vous fait écouter non quand
avez vous fait vous êtes la majorité
quand avez vous fait quelles sont les
lois qui ont été votées suite à ce grand
débat à nous avons organisé la
convention citoyenne c'est typiquement
issu d'une grande époque et quelles sont
les lois qui ont été votées suite à la
convention citoyenne nous avons voté une
loi organique sur neuf l'anticipation
citoyenne pour renforcer le
merveilleux absolument aucune des
mesures principales qui ont été
soutenues par les citoyens dans la
convention n'ont été adopté bon donc
vous avez contribué à renforcer encore
le jeu dire le dégoût c'est peut-être un
beau former le dégoût
des sites où le débat sur le bilan parce
que j'aurai qu'on se projette sur des
suppositions mais j'aurais quand même
vous vous entendre vous aussi avez
marseille sur ce voile assure sur le
bilan du quinquennat maquereau en
matière de de rupture démocratique ou de
fractures effectivement une pratique qui
a glissé
qui fait que ces institutions elles sont
fortes elles ont permis de gouverner
mais en même temps il ya une pratique
institutionnelle
qui est de plus en plus concentré en
clair il ya maintenant l'elysée et la
population parce qu'on peut pas dire
sommes ici parlementaire ne peut pas
dire qu'ils aient beaucoup de débats
parlementaires je parle mutile décision
parlementaire gouvernement il passe les
places et président qui fait des
communiqués qui fait des tweets qui
annoncent des décisions et donc il ya
plus de débat les syndicats sont
quasiment absents donc il n'y a plus de
grands débats et ce que je crains les
vous fait le même constat avant et après
la crise et gilet jaune parce qu'on a
quand même le sentiment qui a eu l'idée
mission qu'elle a renforcé parce que par
nécessité
on a bien vu que l'exécutif était en
situation de devoir a amené des
décisions quelquefois du jour au
lendemain le parlement il était amené à
commenter en quelque sorte souvent vous
avez une décision à la télévision un
jour et puis 48 heures plus tard vous
fait un débat sans vote en disant
écoutez donnez-nous votre opinion si
vous avez besoin de quelque chose
téléphonez-nous bon ok mais je pense que
ça peut pas durer très longtemps parce
que là on voit bien qu'en plus on est
dans une campagne où il n'y a pas de
débat et donc les débats auront lieu
après l'élection ça sans forcer le
pouvoir du parlement ça va être l'un des
thèmes de notre débat devrait donner la
parole une première fois jean phi pour
derosier est ce que vous défendez cette
vème république est-ce qu'il faut
changer de république
je suis un défenseur de la vème
république parce que je pense qu'elle a
apporté à la france tant la démocratie
et la stabilité dans cette dernière
avait besoin
donc je ne suis absolument pas favorable
à un changement de république qui
d'ailleurs ne veut pas dire grand chose
parce que lorsque l'on parle de 6e un
public sous cette notion on fédère tous
les mécontents tous les critiques de
notre régime actuel qui ont pour la
plupart des prétentions très diverses et
si jamais un jour la 6ème république
devait naître dès le lendemain voir le
jour même on en appellerait déjà à la
7ème république fédérant ainsi à nouveau
les mécontents de ce nouveau régime il y
en a toujours c'est bien normal nous
sommes justement dans une démocratie et
les critiques peuvent s'exprimer mais
cela n'empêche pas mon attachement à la
vème république d'être lucide est de
constater que healy à certains
dysfonctionnements ou certains éléments
qui mériterait d'être corrigés ou d'être
améliorés dont vous venez de l'évoquer
un nécessaire renforcement du parlement
pour rééquilibrer les pouvoirs et je
reviendrai vers vous tout à l'heure pour
une excuse ou nous disiez comment vous
vous n'imaginez bastien la chaux la 6ème
république c'est c'est un axe fort de la
campagne de votre candidature mélenchon
d'ailleurs c'était déjà le cas il ya
cinq ans qu'est ce que vous proposez
exactement il faut regarder la situation
de la france d'aujourd'hui par rapport à
celle de 1958 en 1958 il y avait 27 %
d'agriculteurs il y en à 1,5 pour cent
aujourd'hui l'espérance de vie était de
73 ans et les plus de 80 ans bref si on
prend surtout ces domaines la france
d'aujourd'hui n'a plus rien à voir avec
la france de 1958 et pourtant en france
nous avons une particularité nous sommes
une nation politique nous faisons juste
j'aimerais juste qu'on s'arrête qu'on
regarde la photo vous mettez à l'écran
de jean luc mélenchon est ce que vous
trouvez réellement que cette photo n'est
pas problématique pourquoi pourquoi
alors on va la regarder et juste après
en alternance vous avez la photo du
président macron qui devra apparaître et
vous allez voir la différence je pense
que là vous alors vous êtes réalisateur
de l'émission et je vais demander un
autre réalisateur à philippe de mettre
une photo de débat n'est pas contre mais
elle me choque pas cette photo là oui
c'était pas s'était passé là qui étaient
sur bon m mais bon si vous voulez mais
qu'est ce qui les choque dans une photo
de jean luc mélenchon c'est quoi il est
insensible le côté agressif et c'est bon
bref j'ai peur que vous soyez un peu
parano à peut-être cette réflexion parce
que moi ce que je vois un tribun c'est
sans doute l'un des meilleurs tribales
[Musique]
alesi est donc aujourd'hui nous avons
une constitution qui n'est pas lui du
tout en lien avec le peuple de france
aujourd'hui donc il est nécessaire parce
que justement le peuple a abandonné ses
institutions notamment depuis 2005 où
les élus ont été contre le choix du
peuple qui avait voté contre la
constituante européenne eh bien il était
indispensable aujourd'hui de
reconstituer un peuple politique et donc
de refaire peuple et pour refaire peuple
la meilleure manière de faire c'est
changer de constitution
mais le plus important n'est pas temps
de changer de conseiller du nom que le
processus par lequel on va changer de
constitution c'est-à-dire la
constituante c'est à dire élire des
députés qui n'auront pas été élu
auparavant qu'ils ne seront pas élus
après donc ça veut dire si jean luc
mélenchon est président il ya des
législatives latif pour élire une
assemblée devant la vème république qui
va continuer à travailler encore et en
parallèle il y aura un référendum pour
demander aux français s'ils sont
d'accord pour compte pour convoquer une
autre assemblée une assemblée
constituante qui aura pour seul objectif
de rédiger une nouvelle constitution et
l'idée de cette constituante c'est
qu'elle puisse être en lien avec des
comités locaux etc pour qu'il y ait un
bouillonnement pour que le peuple se
saisisse de ces institutions et décide
lui même de quelles sont les règles avec
lesquelles il veut être gouvernés et
c'est à une autre chance le seul moyen
de résoudre aujourd'hui ce problème qui
fait que plus personne ne va voter
pourquoi les gens ne vont plus voter
parce que comme l'a dit le sénateur
marseille aujourd'hui il ya une seule
élection qui compte une seule c'est
l'élection présidentielle toutes les
autres ne sont que la déclinaison de 2,7
alors on comprendra des élections
principale où les français se déplacer
les municipales ils vont voter pour
leurs mets le taux d'abstention a
explosé en allant se disait sans que
vide
pas dire c'est tout ce que les français
vont voter pour la présidentielle et
pour les municipaux les municipales and
soul et non non la dernière élection
municipale le taux d'export d'abstention
a explosé c'était des élections vitraux
voter mais non c'est pas trop facile
qu'il y avait un problème démocratique à
tenir sa sélection
basée à la chaux va détailler certaines
des mesures de jean luc mélenchon je
voudrais vous entendre avec ma soeur sur
l'idée de finalement balayé cette vème
république et passer à autre chose enfin
moi je inventer une autre je crois que
le cadre constitutionnel mais il reste
bon c'est un certain nombre de réformes
qui elles n'ont pas forcément eu des
effets positifs le quinquennat on peut
s'interroger puisqu'on est en élection
permanente deuxièmement l'élection des
députés le lendemain de la
présidentielle que constituante ou pas
quand vous faites les élections des
députés lendemain on a vu ce que ça
donnait ça donne des chambres
introuvable et après bah vous avez
j'allais dire effectivement des textes
qui arrive un parlement qui discute plus
donc il ya ces il ya au moins ces deux
sujets là et revenir à des débats
parlementaires c'est à dire qu'à partir
du moment où vous avez une taie havre et
parlement qui discutent des choses vous
avez un rééquilibrage par rapport à
l'exécutif aujourd'hui force est de
constater et c'est pas nouveau ça fait
un certain nombre d'années avec une
pratique institutionnelle qui renforce
l'exécutif que les débats sont
totalement absents il ya une bonne cuvée
vous avez écrit un rapport justement sur
le renforcement des pouvoirs du du
parlement vous l'avais envoyé au
président en décembre dernier sur il
vous a répondu vous avez parlé j'ai eu
des échanges mais je garderai pour moi
il ya deux trois remarques je voudrais
faire par rapport à ce qui vient d'être
dit moi je suis lassé d'entendre des
parlementaires qui finalement dénigrent
le travail parlementaire moi depuis cinq
ans je préside la commission des lois je
préside les débats qui se tiennent en
commission des lois et j'assiste à plus
de 25% des débats qui sont dans
l'hémicycle je vois bien que le
parlement travaille que le parlement
débat qu'il y à de très nombreux
amendements adoptés qu'il fait évoluer
le texte qui sort du parlement qui est
identique à celui qui est rentré qui
avait été présenté par le gouvernement
alors on peut mieux faire et c'est la
raison pour laquelle j'ai proposé 25
propositions pour renforcer nos pouvoirs
mais aujourd'hui le parlement joue son
rôle nous débattons nous modifions les
textes du gouvernement
nous exerçons notre mission de contrôle
nous évaluons les politiques publiques
nous nous arrivons à faire du travail
trans partisan nous avons nous arrivons
à travailler avec le sénat et à faire ce
qu'on appelle des commissions mixtes
paritaires qui aboutissent avec des
textes qui sont améliorées donc il n'est
pas vrai de dire que le parlement est
une chambre d'enregistrement
et puis j'allais vous dire il ne tient
qu'à nous finalement de faire que le
parlement est pleinement effectif est
saisie de tous ses pouvoirs le mans ce
n'est possible c'est typique aux députés
ne tiennent leur mandat que de la
victoire présidentielle mais les députés
une puce sont là que parce qu'ils ont
été élus grâce aux présidences animaux
d'origine à porte qui à côté du
président macro exact ça n'est pas si
c'est vrai mais si c'était comme ça nous
aurions 577 députés
parce que la sociologie de du pays fait
déjà des circonscriptions mais non
malheureusement vous rigolez mais je ne
comprends pas vous tue fait à ce point
confiance aux français pour leur confier
une assemblée constituante aujourd'hui
vous dénigrer leurs notes du doubs
depuis tout jeune je termine en beauté
sa voiture sont biologiques vive la
république
forcément si
les françaises et les français élisent
un président le jeu donne une majorité
dans la ville
allez j'en reprends la main s'il vous
plaît on va essayer de s'appuyer comme
ça sur quelques exemples de proposition
et je prends comme promis voyez qu'on va
essayer d'être équilibrés une des
mesures phares qui est proposée par jean
luc mélenchon le référendum révocatoire
et on écoute le candidat c'était dans ce
meeting immersif à nantes pour ça qu'on
appliquera le droit de révoquer les élus
lorsque vous estimez qu'il vous ont
trahis
alors dupond moretti a dit ara vous êtes
en train d'inventer le mandat impératif
un élu il doit pouvoir il doit pouvoir
quoi quand on a écouté la fin de son
discours ça voulait dire un élu il a le
droit de pouvoir faire exactement le
contraire de ce que veulent les gens
sans que ceux ci ne puissent rien contre
lui on n'est pas d'accord nous voulons
marié la stabilité des institutions qui
est nécessaire pour gouverner une grande
société nombreuses comme la nôtre et le
pouvoir d'intervention permanent du
peuple à travers des institutions
nouvelles comme le référendum
d'initiative citoyenne
le référendum révocatoire
alors vous allez nous expliquer comment
ça pourrait se mettre en place mais
j'aimerais bien entendre la réaction de
jean philippe derosier sur ce référendum
révocatoire
qu'est ce que vous en pensez il ya
peut-être une critique qu'on pourrait
faire à priori je suis peut-être à côté
de la plaque mais c'est un risque
d'instabilité comment vous le percevez
jeu sans vouloir être excessivement
locateur je pense que c'est une mesure
strictement purement et exclusivement
populistes et qui ne permet pas d'avoir
et de préserver la sérénité nécessaire
du mandat parce que lorsque vous élisez
un responsable politique elle est élue
pour un certain temps on peut entrer
dans un autre débat qui est la durée les
mandales cas échéant mais il s'engage à
effectuer
son mandat a effectué ce à quoi il s'est
engagé face à ses lecteurs pendant une
certaine durée si à tout instant de son
mandat pour quelque cause que ce soit
parce que d'après mes connaissances sans
doute limité en la matière la
proposition de monsieur mélenchon
peut-être la révocation pour quelque
cause que ce soit si donc pour quelque
cause que ce soit il peut être renvoyée
par le peuple cela veut dire que eelv a
constamment cherché non pas à accomplir
son mandat avec l'indépendance qui est
la sienne mais à se soucier
quotidiennement de ce que n'ont pas
attendre ses électeurs mais à plaire à
ses aînés on a bien compris semble bien
qu'on si j'échoue trépigne à l'idée de
vous répondre
je vous redonne la parole dans un
instant jean philippe desrosiers pardon
de vous interrompre mais le temps file
assez vite laetitia très très rapide je
veux juste poser la question est ce
qu'on a demandé aux français est ce
qu'on les a testées pour savoir si oui
ou non ils souhaitaient eux avoir plus
de pouvoirs et eux décidé davantage
parce que là j'ai l'impression que ce
sont les élites vous en faites partie
monsieur qui sont en train de discuter
entre elles de comment mieux distribuer
le pouvoir vers le peuple on va quand
même les faire participer mais est-ce
que vous avez des confrontations à on
peut dire que considérer que cette
élection présidentielle c'est une
consultation pour choisir entre les
candidats ont envie d'être consultés
régulièrement dans le prochain mandat
pour une demande des villes et jaune
l'essentiel du sud et gilet jaune le
risque et nous avons été sages et puis
je vous réponds oui nous avons testé les
yeux comme cela n'aura finalement pas
sophie répondez moi que je vous répond
calmement mais si vous regardez il ya eu
plusieurs sondages qui ont été faits aux
journalistes vous adorez les sondages
donc vous voyez la politique les aime
bien aussi donc vous pouvez leur faire
confiance une majorité des français est
favorable au référendum d'initiative
citoyenne et notamment au droit de
révoquer les élus donc pour répondre
monsieur desrosiers nous serons ravis
d'apprendre qu'une majorité des états
américains ont une législation
populistes voire même l'état de
californie à qui il y a quelques années
a révoqué son gouverneur au nom d'un
droit de révocation le principe de
révoquer les élus tout simplement veut
dire qu'un élu est élu sur un programme
si les électeurs se rendent compte
qu'ils n'appliquent pas à son programme
au lieu d'attendre cinq en six ans la
fin de son mandat eh bien à mi mandat
ils peuvent si x % du corps électoral
signent une pétition exiger un
référendum révocatoire cela ne veut pas
dire révoqué et ça veut dire qu'il y
aura une nouvelle concept construit
consultations sur cette question en quoi
est-ce créer de l'instabilité au
contraire cela responsabilise les lui
face à ses électeurs et cela donne un
pouvoir supplémentaire aux électeurs et
donc cela à mon avis renforce la
confiance entre les élus et leurs
électeurs alors un bras apprendre que
les situations
avait fait radom de la suspecte
l'idée qu'il ya des développer mais je
la combattent hôtes allemands c'est pas
possible je crois que l'idée nous ce que
nous défendons c'est d'amener plus de
débats plus de valeur au parlement et
qu'il n'en a plus ou quasiment plus nos
yeux donc par exemple on parle beaucoup
d'énergie y a pas eu un seul débat sur
l'énergie on revient au nucléaire on
voit pas mais il n'y a pas eu un seul
débat les seuls qui ont eu droit à un
débat c'est la convention citoyenne et
on sait comment ça a fini bon donc mais
ce pardon je vous interromps si on prend
l'exemple d'un d'un député qui a été élu
sur dans une famille politique et qui
change de faillite politique au milieu
de son mandat est ce qu'on pourrait
considérer que les électeurs ont un
droit de regard
l'évolution dans le temps et je dire il
ya des situations les ceux qui ont été
élus à l'assemblée nationale il ya cinq
ans entre temps il s'est passé
énormément de choses enfin je veux dire
on peut aussi évoluer en fonction du
contexte national international européen
s'est pas linéaire c'est pour ça rien
compris donc vous êtes vous favorable
comme je me douche avant les titres on
va parler du du pouvoir du président
dans nos institutions laetitia vous
donne la parole parce qu'il ya il ya on
va s'appuyer sur la gestion de la crise
sanitaire c'est quand même une assez
bonne illustration c'est la meilleure
parce que c'est une exception française
cette crise sanitaire a été gérée par le
fameux conseil de défense sanitaire qui
était complètement opaque dans les
délibérations
ne sortait jamais aucune transparence
sur la façon dont les décisions ont été
prises et on se demande alors je suis
allé un petit peu cherché je vais juste
faire un tout petit peu de pédagogie ce
conseil national de défense et l'article
15 de la constitution de la vème
république le permet mais emmanuel
macron y accoler le terme sanitaire
c'est un nouveau lit adroit pourquoi
parce qu'il ya un décret de 2009 qui
stipule que le conseil de défense
nationale a pour mission la
planification des réponses aux crises
majeures donc la crise sanitaire étant
une crise majeure il a constitué il a
inauguré ce conseil national de défense
sanitaire sauf que ils ont rythmé la
pandémie et sa entretenu il me semble un
climat de défiance pourquoi parce qu'on
savait que c'était en tout petit comité
il y avait le prix sema public le
premier ministre et quelques ministres
ou à quatre ministres certaines
personnalités ils étaient réunis dans le
salon murat de l'elysée et encore une
fois il y avait à l'issue de cette
réunion une décision verticale dont on
comprenait parfaitement qu'elle émanait
d'un seul homme emmanuel macron donc
bien sûr que cette façon de dire en plus
aux français quoi faire parce que vous
voyez bien un impact direct c'était
d'annoncer des restrictions donc de nos
vies dans nos vies quotidiennes et
c'était un homme emmanuel macron qui
décidèrent de
double de nos vies quotidiennes il
s'agit au fond ça me fait réagir parce
que moi j'ai en tant que président de
commission
hu à gérer l'ensemble des textes
sanitaires depuis deux ans c'est treize
textes qui sont passés au parlement est
en fait à chaque fois le parlement a
donné l'autorisation au gouvernement
pour prendre un certain nombre de
décisions donc c'est ça s'est fait à
chaque fois sur délégation du parlement
avec à chaque fois des conditions un
contrôle accru une date limite dans le
temps et c'est pour ça qu'il ya très ce
texte parce que en fait tous les trois
mois en gros on était à nouveau devant
le parlement donc le rôle du parlement
et effectivement c'est là qu'elle est
l'exception française c'est que nous
sommes un des rares pays en europe à
avoir une intervention aussi accru du
parlement sur cette aide socialité dans
l'hérault vient des régions qui
participe à la sauvegarde du parlement
nous avons autorisé par la loi le
gouvernement à agir nous aurons un débat
encore la semaine prochaine au parlement
sur ces questions tout dépend des
ministres de la santé devenu le ministre
qui fréquent que plus la commission ça
ne s'est jamais vu il a à chaque fois
répondu à mes convocations monsieur
delfraissy a été auditionné plusieurs
fois en commission des lois il est faux
de considérer que c'est ce sont des
prises de décisions unilatérales et
uniquement descendants ça ne correspond
pas à la réalité encore aujourd'hui j'ai
reçu un rapport au parlement un
premier mini cette crise sanitaire le
temps finalement des responsables au
cours de cette crise sanitaire at elle
renforcé le pouvoir présidentiel se fait
pourquoi le conseil de défense parce
qu'il ya un sujet là encore parce que le
gouvernement n'est plus comme il le
devrait être responsable politiquement
devant le parlement que il est obligé si
je puis dire d'utiliser ce cet artifice
quel conseil de défense pour éviter les
juges parce que c'est vrai qu'il ya un
tas de gens qui ford et à tort ou à
raison j'en sais rien qui déposent des
plaintes c'est sûrement excessive
quelque part et donc on se réfugie
derrière le conseil de défense qui est
un organe effectivement quand on sait
pas ce qui se passe et qui est opaque
alors que le gouvernement devrait être
responsable devant le parlement
politiquement révoqué mais
qu'est ce qui se passe c'est d'ailleurs
il ya tellement d'autres malheureusement
donné bas que les gens attaquent
directement soit par la justice soit par
la violence institutionnelle soit
conseil d'état à état non ça sert à rien
avec son parlement puisque le débat
aller on va parler de la proportionnelle
un mot rapide là dessus non mais moi je
rejoins pleinement ce que ce que vous
avez dit c'est la démonstration que tous
ceux décidés par un seul homme les
textes arrivée au parlement la veille
pour être voté pour le lendemain et même
pas le temps d examiner sérieusement ici
c'est vrai est en tout cas ce qui est
certain c'est qu'une des premières
mesures que nous prendrons ce sera de
lever le secret défense sur la totalité
des des conseils de défense sanitaire
pour que l'on sache enfin ce qui s'y est
dit voilà ce que voilà un des
engagements clairs que nous posons pour
la transparence gmt derosier est ce que
le l'exécutif c'est un peu tordu la
constitution et notamment cet article 15
dont parlait laetitia à l'instant
sur ce thème spécifique là il n'y a pas
eu de démarche anticonstitutionnelle
sinon ça a été rappelé le juge a été
saisie et le juge l'aurait leur est
censuré mais à l'action démocratique
elle est à faire effectivement leur elle
n'est pas faire aussi de communication
de symboles et de transparence et c'est
là où effectivement on peut avoir un
petit doute sur la volonté de
transparence de l'exécutif qui règlent
une crise majeure sous l'aune d'un
organe qui n'est pas réellement habilité
à gérer une crise sanitaire lorsque l'on
parle conseil de défense lorsque le code
de la défense évoque les crises majeures
elle pas anticiper les questions
sanitaires c'était des crises en matière
de sécurité et de défense lorsque le
président hollande convoquer le conseil
de défense lorsqu'il ya eu des attentats
en 2015 jusqu'à la fin de son mandat
c'est compréhensible mais ce n'est pas
un conseil de défense immunitaire ni
d'anti les questions et donc c'est là où
effectivement ça peut un petit peu
interpellé allez si vous parle était
juste et en qui seconde un mot
supplémentaire cela s'inscrit dans une
démarche effectivement de non respect de
notre démocratie et de notre parlement
et cette question du respect des hommes
et des femmes qui composent des
institutions et les institutions
elles-mêmes c'est pas une affaire de
règles c'est une affaire de pratiquer le
général de gaulle avait dit qu'une
institution c'est un esprit des
institutions est une pratique et il
serait bon de veiller à l'ensemble
d'entre elles on va ouvrir le chapitre
proportionnelle dans ce dans cette
émission et j'appelle laurent mauriac le
rédacteur en chef du site bref mis à à
nous rejoindre
partenaires pendant cette présidentielle
est ce qu'on va voir revenir la
proportionnelle comme ses prédécesseurs
et même macron avait annoncé et a
finalement renoncé à introduire une dose
de proportionnelle pour les législatives
oui en effet après nicolas sarkozy puis
françois hollande emmanuel macron
s'était engagé sur ce sujet et il a
renoncé et voici ce que le président de
la république déclarait en juillet 2010
est devant le parlement
la représentativité reste toutefois un
combat inachevé dans notre pays je
souhaite le mener avec vous résolument
je proposerai ainsi que le parlement
soit élu avec une dose de
proportionnelle
pour que toutes les sensibilités
ils soient justement représentés mais
voilà après laffaire benalla les gilet
jaune la crise du coc vide les priorités
ont changé et en mars 2021 les chefs de
groupe de la majorité à l'assemblée ont
estimé que les conditions n'étaient pas
réunies pour mener cette réforme à bien
et françois bayrou n'a pas eu plus de
succès avec son idée d'un référendum
le sujet a été renvoyée au prochain
quinquennat alors à faire c'est quoi en
faire une bonne vieille colonnes plus
école mois dans la colonne plus les
arguments en faveur alors on s'affaire
comme on l'a entendu avec emmanuel
macron c'est une meilleure
représentativité des électeurs à
l'assemblée alors si on regarde en 2017
avec le scrutin en vigueur le scrutin
majoritaire la république en marche a
obtenu 28 % des voix mais 53 % des
sièges al'inverse le front national a
recueilli 13 % des voix mais seulement
un pour cent des sièges la france
insoumise 11% des voix 3 % des sièges
maintenant alors dans la colonne dans
l'autre colonnes il ya la crainte d'une
instabilité politique elle est nourrie
par le souvenir de la quatrième
république et par l'observation de pays
étrangers par exemple israël a dû
organiser quatre scrutins entre 2019 et
2021 on a une citation de jacques chirac
sur ce thème là c'est ça alors vous
l'avez plus d'un alors si moi je les sur
la fiche mais vous l'avez vous l'avez à
fait malheureux ça c'est la vie
la chaîne était bien oui vous rentrez
dans l'église à la santé oms n'a pas pu
avoir cette archive brèves escales une
voie médiane oui alors c'est pour ça
qu'on parle de dose de proportionnelle
pour viser une plus grande
représentativité sans prendre le risque
d'une plus grande instabilité alors en
quoi cela peut consister en février 2021
le député modem patrick mignola a
proposé l'instauration de la
proportionnelle mais seulement dans les
départements qui élisent au moins au
moins 12 députés d'autres systèmes sont
possibles par exemple le fait de voter
deux fois en même temps une fois pour un
candidat de sa circonscription et une
deuxième fois pour un parti comme c'est
le cas en allemagne et la composition de
la chambre est issu de ce double mode de
scrutin pour l'instant les candidats à
la présidentielle souhaite pour la
plupart introduire une dose de
proportionnelle mais vous l'avez compris
c'est devenu une habitude pour les
candidats mais c'est après que ça se
complique mais évidemment remercie
beaucoup et pardon de ses deux se
chausse trapes
bascule sur internet est gratuite mais
quand on est une chaîne de télévision
c'est compliqué et on respecte la
diffusion et les droits évidemment yale
brand peavey bon set cette promesse est
là elle n'a pas été tenue
pourquoi pourquoi aimer c'est pas le
seul à on l'a dit avant lui françois
hollande avant lui nicolas sarkozy c'est
une belle promesse de candidat quoi
c'est une promesse à laquelle nous
tenions et à laquelle nous tenons
toujours effectivement cette dose de
proportionnelle ce système intermédiaire
qui permet d'assurer une meilleure
représentation des français et en même
temps la stabilité du régime et une
majorité qui permettent au gouvernement
de mettre en oeuvre le programme pour
lequel le président de la république a
été élu nous l'avions proposé et nous
avons commencé à examiner les textes
mais la réforme s'est heurtée à
effectivement l'épisode benalla et puis
à une hostilité du sénat qui ne voulait
pas entendre mais il y avait vraiment et
son fils younes on
n'a pas réussi et ça ne vous aura pas
échappé à réformer la constitution
durant cette mandature lorsque nous
avons voulu réformer la constitution sur
le climat en simplement modifiant
l'article 1 de la constitution le sénat
nous a opposé une fin de non recevoir
donc on a eu un réel problème une réelle
difficulté à mettre en oeuvre les
réformes institutionnelles avec un
blocage c'est dehors du sénat
effectivement il faudra y revenir
pendant la prochaine mandature quel que
soit celui qui sera élu puisque vous
l'avez rappelé les français sont très
largement favorables à une dose de
proportionnelle c est ce que c'est le
sénat qui a bloqué bon je compose je
crois pas
actuel à la présidence de la commission
des lois que c'est pas totalement comme
ça si on part du principe qu'on nous dit
voilà il ya une phrase au toucher à rien
c'est à prendre ou à laisser
effectivement c'est pas ce qu'on peut
appeler un dialogue banques
je rappelle quand même que le sénat les
sénateurs sont et vit à 70 % à la
proportionnelle bon on n'est pas hostile
à la proportionnelle le problème c'est
de savoir quel type de proportionnelle
parce qu'il ya une variété infinie de
proportionnelle régionales nationales
départementales avec plus ou moins de
doses majoritaire un peu comme aux
municipales
je crois qu'on peut effectivement mettre
de la proportionnelle et avoir malgré
tout la stabilité donc je crois que le
sénat était disponible pendant le
quinquennat très sincèrement c'est pas
la faute de l'assemblée nationale mais
on peut pas dire que le sénat ait été
très considéré de la part de l'exécutif
chaque fois qu'il a pu être contourné
en jambes et ça a été fait immédiatement
donc le sénat a toujours été disponible
pour la proportionnelle et il faudra
parce qu'on peut pas avoir environ 35 à
40% de l'électorat qui n'est pas
représenté alors qu'est ce que vous
proposez qu'est ce que propose jean luc
mélenchon est ce que c'est une
proportionnelle intégrale que propose
jean luc mélenchon nous proposons de
revenir au système 1986 c'est à dire une
proportionnelle par département ce qui
me permet en effet de mieux garantir la
stabilité que la proportionnelle
intégrale mais ce qui permet aussi de
traiter l'ensemble des citoyens de la
même manière et égalitairement parce que
s'il ya des départements à la
proportionnelle d'autres un scrutin
majoritaire il y aura des personnes qui
ne seront toujours pas toujours pas
représentés mais juste madame brand qui
vais modifier le mode de scrutin
n'implique pas de modifier la
constitution une loi organique suffit
pour modifier le scrutin donc nous
aurions pu modifier et revenir à la
proportionnelle sans attente de modifier
la constitution à cincy je crois que
c'est une façon mais nous avions un pack
je supportais révision constitutionnelle
mais
je sais bien mais à partir du moment où
la loi constitutionnelle n'a pas pu être
adoptée vous auriez pu adopter la
proposition de loi déposée par le modem
d'une proportionnelle vous ne l'avez pas
voulu donc de dites pas que c'est une
promesse qui vous tient à coeur c'est
une promesse que vous n'avez pas
appliquée pourquoi parce qu'ils avaient
peur de ne pas avoir la majorité j'ai dû
perdre des sièges non non c'est pas vrai
vous n'auriez pas eu 330 d'élus avec la
proportionnelle perdu leurs yeux nous
avons une vision globale de la réforme
des institutions nous pardonner nos
oncles à
s'intégrer dans cette vision globale
après le fait de savoir si c'est une loi
ordinaire organique ou une loi
constitutionnelle ça c'est de la
tambouille gens n'ont pas du tout d'où
on a un pack on sait le pas qui nous
fait d'ailleurs le pack avec diminution
du nombre de parlementaires avec moins
de pouvoirs pour le parlement est en
effet là on peut leur donner les
pensionnaires
et ça c'est mon rapport j'espère que
vous l'avez lu je lui ai adressé alors
je donne la parole maintenant
jean-philippe de rosée sur cette
question de la proportionnelle jean
philippe derosier est effectivement on à
laurent mauriac donner l'exemple
d'israël c'est vrai que ça a été a
presque caricatural pendant ces ces deux
années comment vous de votre
bureau de constitutionnalistes vous
expliquer finalement les réticences des
trois derniers présidents français sur
ce thème
alors il ya cette crainte de
l'instabilité effectivement parce que
l'expérience française sans aller jusqu
en israël qui est également tout à fait
l'exemple approprié aujourd'hui mais
l'histoire constitutionnelle française
notamment celle de la quatrième
république montre que le scrutin
proportionnel
ouvre la voie à de très grande
instabilité et surtout le scrutin
proportionnel contrairement aux
apparences et beaucoup moins
démocratique que le scrutin majoritaire
et je sais que cela peut surprendre
parce que comme cela était très
justement dit le scrutin proportionnel
permet d'offrir une image plus fidèle de
la diversité et des opinions politiques
mais
n'oublions pas que la démocratie c'est
le gouvernement du peuple par le peuple
et pour le peuple il ne faut pas oublier
le gouvernement la capacité de gouverner
et surtout l'un comme l'autre mais jeux
proportionnelle au majoritaire
conduisent nécessairement vers des
coalitions or dans le cadre du scrutin
proportionnel les coalitions se font
toujours après le vote donc à l'abri des
regards des électeurs qui ne peuvent pas
se prononcer là où pour le scrutin
majoritaire les accords de coalitions
loft avoir lieu en amont puisqu'il faut
se répartir les circonscriptions et donc
les électeurs se prononcent sur cet
accord je prends juste un exemple en 15
secondes qui illustre parfaitement cela
en 2017 en allemagne il ya eu des
élections législatives au terme de ce
que l'on appelle une grande coalition
c'est à dire une coalition entre les
chrétiens démocrates le parti d'angela
merkel à l'époque et le spd les sociaux
démocrates
le spd a fait toute sa campagne en
disant jamais plus jamais nous ne
gouvernerons avec les
chrétiens-démocrates et au lendemain des
élections de septembre 2010 est qu'est
ce qu'il y a eu au pouvoir une coalition
entre les chrétiens-démocrates et les
sociaux démocrates parce que ni l'un ni
l'autre n'ont obtenu la majorité absolue
et ils ont été contraints de gouverner
ensemble et cela s'est fait donc à
rebours des promesses électorales et qui
a gagné les élections suivantes en
allemagne le spd donc les électeurs lui
ont nourri les électeurs lui on en tenue
rire et la bonne fée les électeurs lui
ont noté ni rien blague à part blague à
part expliqué que le fait que 35% des
citoyens ne sont pas représentés à
l'assemblée nationale il est un système
plus démocratique que le fait que
l'ensemble des opinions politiques
d'histoire présentée c'est vraiment
caricatural vous êtes bien député
monsieur la chaux oui 3 % des députés
trois personnes des députés pour la
france est soumise pour 11 % 2
du scrutin 3% pour 11% vous trouvez que
c'est normal
où trouver
parce que les français ne vont plus
voter on a bien
en fait on voit bien que la
proportionnelle intégrale et se marie
bien avec un régime parlementaire nous
nous avons une élection du président de
la république au suffrage universel avec
le président de la république un certain
nombre de pouvoirs le parlement ne peut
pas avoir le premier ministre doit tirer
sa légitimité du président de la
république et non pas d'une coalition
parlementaire on a une confrontation qui
ne serait pas qui ne serait pas juste
donc vraiment une dose de
proportionnelle pour mieux représenter
les français et assurer une majorité ça
me semble mercredi bonne équipe beaucoup
merci à tous d'avoir participé à ce
débat merci à toutes les équipes de
public sénat ici en régie à la rédaction
de sens public voilà c'est super à la
programmation c'est un bonheur de bosser
avec vous je vous dis à lundi et
n'oubliez pas la matinale évidemment
rayonnement signé demain sont invités
c'est jean christophe lagarde le
président de l'udps lille et publie
seine saint denis j'ai ouïe et président
du groupe udf
on